this video is made possible by blinkist
do you manage to read all the books that
you want to get all the knowledge that
you need probably not right
everyone is busier than ever it's harder
than ever to spend time learning and
even when you try there are so many
distractions like that tempting video
about some nonsense down there on the
right or maybe it's the opposite right
now you're stuck at home due to the
coronavirus and the thought of going to
a library or browsing a bookshop seems
too risky or you might think that you
don't have enough time to read
good news even if you don't you do if
you use blinkist blinkist
is an app that takes the best insights
and needs to know info from thousands of
non-fiction books and condenses them
into 15-minute summaries which you can
read or listen to they have
a huge library and 14 million users 14
million
the team at visualpolitik are happy
blinkist customers we find that we can
actually fit reading a book on blinkist
into a short break time or a commute to
a shoot whilst keeping up with a pretty
crazy work schedule they've got tons of
popular titles like
thinking fast and slow from daniel
kahneman also tons of political books
and if you want to take a look back at
the history they've got great condensed
versions of books like the silk roads by
peter francapan
the first 100 people to go to
blinkist.com forward slash visualpolitik
are going to get unlimited access
for one week to try it out you'll also
get 25
off if you want the full membership move
fast get started on catching up on all
those great books that you haven't got
around to reading
the seven day trial is completely free
and you can cancel at any time during
that trial if you're not completely into
it but we think you will be
[Applause]
and now for something new from us dear
friends
over the years vladimir putin and donald
trump have already graced visualpolitik
with their presence
so we thought that now is a good time to
change continents are you ready to meet
the new arrival
well let's get started
in the chinese astrological calendar the
year 2020 coincided with the year of the
rat a period that according to chinese
astrologers would come loaded with
opportunities
abundance and prosperity however no
matter how much of a rat's year it was
things started off badly the persistence
of the trade war and particularly the
sars coronavirus ii pandemic put the
chinese economy in check by february
2020 all the forecasts indicated that
the asian giant would have to face a
huge storm
a tidal wave an entire economic
hurricane and not only that
during this past year we've also seen
what has perhaps been the most
aggressive and nationalistic face of
china
in recent decades and if you think for a
moment that i'm exaggerating let's recap
the facts
during the year of the rat china crushed
hong kong's political freedoms
intensified its pressure on taiwan
further fueled what has come to be known
as the new cold war against the united
states
unleashed a huge wave of repression in
xinjiang against the minority wieger
population
sent troops to the border with india and
launched a trade punishment operation
against australia for having dared to
call for a serious investigation into
the origin of saskaronovirus ii during
that same year
china even went so far as to pass a new
export control law a law by which the
export of certain products considered as
strategic
requires the express approval of the
chinese government
we are talking about commercial
exchanges such as the trade of minerals
known as rare earth elements
but of course the products considered
strategic are arbitrarily chosen by the
government so anything that comes to
mind could be included on this list in
other words to be completely clear
this new law is basically a new weapon
that china could use in response to a
trade war or a campaign of political
pressure anyway i think that's quite a
lot for one year
don't you
certainly no one can accuse the chinese
leaders of sleeping on the job even if
it wasn't exactly the kind of things
we'd like to tell you about
not surprisingly all these actions
carried out by xi jinping's government
have not only received enormous amounts
of criticism and condemnation but have
also increased the geopolitical risks of
investing in the great asian giant not
to mention
sinking its image all over the planet
especially among developed countries
unfavorable views of china reach
historic highs
in many countries pew research well the
fact is that between the trade war the
coronavirus the collapse of china's
reputation and all the things that we've
seen china carry out during the past
year the abundance and prosperity
promised by the year of the rat
seemed a more erroneous prognosis than
that of steve bulmer former ceo of
microsoft when he said that the iphone
had no chance of success
however hold on a moment because it
turns out that in the case of china
things unfolded very differently even
with all the obstacles that 2020 threw
at them
china's economy expands at faster rate
than before coronavirus
gdp rises 6.5 in fourth quarter as other
big economies
struggle to recover from pandemic
financial times
and of course given what has been seen
in the rest of the world question the
big question we can all ask ourselves is
what on earth happened with china well
dear friends the truth is that against
all odds although it may surprise you
more than tesla presenting a
diesel-powered car
2020 was one of the most successful
years since xi jinping has been in power
and take note because i'm not just
talking about his nationalistic
political campaign listen up because in
this video we are going to tell you the
story of how xi jinping inflicted a
heavy defeat
on the great american power the united
states of america in 2020 let's
get started
[Music]
against all odds
okay it may come as a complete shock but
if we're talking about politics and
economics
china ended the year of the coronavirus
much stronger than it started the asian
giant was one of the few major economies
that ended the year with positive
economic growth
reinforced its role in world trade and
affirmed its role as the world's factory
perhaps the fact that best represents
this evolution is that while halfway
around the world economies were
collapsing due to the advance of the
coronavirus in december 2020
china announced the eradication of
extreme poverty in its territory and
friends
on this occasion experts suggest that
this claim may not be an exaggeration on
the part of the government
there are still poor people in china of
course but according to the world bank
over the last four decades 800 million
chinese have come out of poverty and now
according to the chinese government
there are no longer pockets of extreme
poverty
throughout the country this is a huge
achievement considering that
in 1978 shortly after mao's death the
vast majority of the chinese population
lived in
extreme poverty and what can i say
achieving such a milestone in 2020 has
to be at least
twice as impressive
china was the country where saskaronna
virus ii first emerged and therefore was
the first country hit by the pandemic
during the first few months of the
fateful year of the rat
we saw tremendous images of how kovid 19
was wreaking havoc
just as we also witnessed a very very
strong response from the chinese
government the first confinements and
probably the toughest coronavirus
eradication measures in the world were
put in place here the result is that the
chinese government not only managed to
completely stop the spread of the
coronavirus but also
despite the fierce hit it took with
historic falls in economic production
achieved a full
v-shaped recovery
[Music]
side note keep in mind as we've told you
before the official data of the asian
giant arouses many doubts
however on this occasion all the
alternative data used to check the
veracity of the official economic
information such as the evolution of
bank loans
electricity production activity in the
ports exports to china from other
countries etc
all point in the same direction the
chinese economy closed 2020
at full capacity
[Music]
another example in the same vein is that
while
foreign direct investment plummeted for
much of 2020 in the united states and
europe in china it stored for a brief
period and soon took off again between
january and november it increased by
more than six percent compared to the
same period
in 2019 with the data in hand what we
saw in 2020
is the clear manifestation of how the
united states has resoundingly lost its
trade war dear friends
back in 2018 donald trump wrote this on
twitter
when a country usa is losing many
billions of dollars
on trade with virtually every country it
does business with
trade wars are good and easy to win
donald trump
on twitter of course the story since
then has been very different
washington launched into a whole bout of
tariffs and barriers to trade of all
kinds but the results have not been
quite as expected
look while the trade deficit of the u.s
power has continued to break records in
china's weight in world trade has barely
suffered and in 2020 the weight of
chinese exports in total global exports
has exceeded the figures before the
trade war in fact
in the end during the year of the rat
the chinese giant
achieved the second largest trade
surplus in its history
more than 535 billion dollars the demand
for chinese products is so strong
that now the problem is that there is
not enough capacity in the ports
in other words the enormous u.s efforts
that have punished its own consumers
companies and producers have been worth
practically nothing
and that's not even the end of it to top
it off the year of the pandemic proved
that against all odds the asian giant is
still the most reliable factory on the
planet
[Music]
in this way after managing to keep the
coronavirus under control
industrial activity was completely
restored and while production chains in
many countries were suffering from
supply problems
in china any company had practically any
supplier it needed working at full
capacity in fact if anything
2020 made it clear that this network
effect having virtually all your
suppliers in the same country is simply
a huge
advantage and that that's precisely what
explains things like this
[Music]
a hsbc investment bank survey conducted
in november 2020 among more than 1100
global corporations
shows no less than 75 percent of large
industrial companies
expect to increase their direct
investments in china including 70
of us companies
[Music]
i'm sorry but the numbers are just
overwhelming the arm wrestle between
donald trump and xi jinping has been won
overwhelmingly by the chinese leader of
course this was by no means their only
victory in 2020 listen up for the global
game change that is taking place
xi jinping's best match
on the 15th of november a historic
agreement was announced and was perhaps
xi jinping's greatest political victory
on that day 15 countries in the
asia-pacific region including the three
economic giants
china japan and south korea signed the
so-called regional comprehensive
economic partnership
establishing the largest trading bloc in
the world by far
this is a block that covers more than
2.3 billion people
and 30 of the entire global economy we
are talking about a treaty that is
estimated to boost regional trade by
hundreds and hundreds of billions of
dollars whilst regulating
under common rules and standards not
only trading goods and services but also
cross-border investment
and e-commerce throughout the region a
region that has already become the
economic epicenter
of the world
[Music]
and friends as you can imagine china is
of course at the heart
of this whole agreement intra-asian
trade which is already larger than
asia's trade with north america and
europe combined will continue to drive
global economic growth and pull the
economic center
of gravity toward asia stuart tate
regional head of commercial banking for
asia pacific
hsbc friends while donald trump decided
to pull the us out of the trans-pacific
partnership
as soon as he came to power at that very
moment china stepped on the gas to get
its own deal and a much bigger one to
boot an agreement that will not only
boost the chinese economy but also
gradually bring many of the us's main
allies closer to the chinese giant
for example because of this agreement 86
of japanese exports to china will be
free of tariffs and in the case of south
korea this figure will rise to over 90
so you see even if the new american
president joe biden decides to rejoin
the tpp u.s dominance in the region and
its ability to influence will not be the
same as it once was
let's pop it all off a few days after
the signing of this agreement xi jinping
himself
expressed the possibility that china
would ask to join the tpp
independently which would cause a real
headache in washington and would give
china the possibility of leading the two
biggest trade agreements in the world
whilst the united states
would not be a part of either
[Music]
but friends the november agreement was
not the only win that the chinese
leader's diplomatic strategy had
in 2020. on the night of 30th for
december it was announced that china
and the european union had reached an
investment agreement after more than six
years of negotiations an agreement that
will facilitate investment by many
european companies in some sectors in
china such as the automotive sector
which is a key step can you guess who
for
exactly germany volkswagen pours more
than
2 billion into china's electric car
industry wall street journal german
automaker raises its share
in a chinese electric vehicle joint
venture and buys a stake
in a battery producer but we are talking
about an agreement that above all is a
diplomatic slap in the face for joe
biden's new administration why
[Music]
because the new president of the united
states together with his national
security adviser jake sullivan had asked
the european union not to sign this pact
and to form a partnership in its
agreements with china from now on
in other words instead of each
negotiating freely they should negotiate
jointly and tell xi jinping hey she
check it out you're talking to no less
than 40
of the world economy however for the
time being europe has preferred to
ignore the first call of the new us
administration looks like another round
goes to china doesn't it
the deal will deepen the economic ties
between china
and the eu with negotiating a free trade
agreement being the expected
next step wu jimbo director of the
center for american studies
at fudon university in shanghai even in
the current geopolitical order china has
repeatedly demonstrated its willingness
to use its economic power
as a strategic weapon by deepening their
economic reliance on china
without coordinating their policy with
fellow democracies european nations are
increasing their vulnerability to
pressure from beijing
gideon rockman financial times chief
foreign affairs commentator
well friends there is yet another field
in which the asian giant showed
outstanding results in 2020 finance
yes despite all attempts by the trump
administration over the past few years
china's financial integration with the
rest of the world
has skyrocketed and 2020 was no
exception more specifically it was quite
a good year for chinese interests in
this area to give you an idea of what
we're talking about
foreign holdings of chinese bonds
increased in 2020 by 49
on the previous year and if we're
talking about stock market investments
then the pitcher is very similar it's a
trend that includes a lot of
international financial giants that are
landing in the asian country
thanks to the new facilities approved by
the chinese government basically
western money is rushing to finance the
chinese economy at full speed
i continue to firmly believe that china
will be one of the biggest
opportunities for blackrock over the
long term both for asset managers
and investors larry fink president and
ceo
of blackrock the world's largest asset
management company
we will soon be talking in detail about
this matter here on visualpolitik with
our friends
from value school in short as you can
see 2020 was a very good year for
china's interests all around the world
not even the coronavirus or the
controversial occupation of hong kong
have changed this reality of course
let's take a minute because all of this
doesn't mean that china's future path is
completely clear
beware of bad practices
friends thanks to the enormous economic
growth it's registered over the last
decades china today has the second
largest economy
in the world the largest trade surplus
the largest financial reserves
and their navy even has the largest
number of military vessels in the world
but hold on because although it seems
that the chinese giant is taking on the
world the growing authoritarianism
and interventionalism of xi jinping's
government poses risks
[Music]
for example since 2007 china's rate of
growth has almost
halved and its productivity has been
reduced the loss of skilled workers
remains significant and outstanding debt
has increased eight-fold especially in
inefficient public enterprises
in this way although the chinese
economic growth rate appears to have
been dazzling
if we compare it with the one recorded
by the famous asian dragons
things get a little bit more blurred and
this this brings up the burning question
how close is china to the united states
but friends we will also be talking
about this
very soon in an upcoming video on the
channel so again don't forget to
subscribe
if you aren't yet and that said it's
over to you what do you think of china
what do you make of its growing
international clout
how do you think western countries
should react leave your answers down in
the comments below so i really hope you
enjoyed this video please hit like if
you did and don't forget to subscribe
for brand new videos and as always
i'll see you in the next video if you
want to learn more about politics and
world affairs and hear some more of my
lovely voice come check out the
reconsider podcast where we don't
do the thinking for you find reconsider
at www.reconcil
or on apple or google play or your
favorite podcatcher